j'ai employé le mot d'enfer pour les
soignants ce sera un enfer aussi pour
les petits commerces de proximité
j'ai eu des témoignages y lire sur les
différentes chaînes d'information qui
sont bouleversants vraiment ce sont des
gens qui se disent on mais on va crever
permettez moi l'expression sur le plan
économique
et quand on crève sur le plan économique
on peut aussi avoir des conséquences sur
le plan moral sanitaire sociale en tout
cas donc moi j'ai une pensée pour eux ce
que j'espère c'est que ce soir quand les
annonces seront faites dans la
conférence de presse de monsieur castex
et bien il y aura des mesures
extraordinaires de soutien financier il
faut mettre sous perfusion ce secteur
perfusion financière
et puisque la le ruissellement des
dettes publiques est maintenant actée
écoutez je vais vous dire on est on est
plus à un ou deux milliards près il
faudra débloquer de l'argent faire de la
dette pour pouvoir aider pendant un mois
deux mois ce secteur la gagne alors les
nageurs
[Musique]